[Music]
peter parker spends his time in no way
home trying to send the multi-versus
villains back home but what happens in
their worlds once they get there and
wait when exactly are they coming from
these confusing moments and more
explained next no way home opens at
exactly the point where far from home
ended a breaking news report from the
daily bugle's incorrigible jay jonah
jameson reveals two key pieces of
information to the world spider-man is
peter parker and he killed mysterio it's
no surprise that mysterio was able to
capture footage of peter to be released
after his death but how exactly did the
villain manage to convince the world
that spider-man had murdered him and
unleashed a drone army right from the
start there were some major flaws in
mysterio's posthumous plan for one thing
anyone in london during mysterio's
attack would have been able to see that
spider-man was battling all the drones
that attacked the city even though
mysterio managed to fake peter's voice
ordering the drones to strike it's hard
to believe that not a single camera in
london captured some footage of the web
slinger's good deeds because all
mysterio's framing plot could rely on
was some faked audio and footage of
himself merely saying that spider-man
was about to attack him it all fell
apart pretty quickly peter crawled his
way out of any legal troubles with ease
but there's always someone who will fall
for conspiracy theory most of the world
might be convinced of spider-man's
innocence but jameson and the bugle's
fans are still holding out for solid
proof of spider-man's misdeeds
peter being outed as spider-man causes
problems for just about everyone in his
life to him it suddenly looks like the
future he envisioned for himself happily
studying at college alongside his best
friend and girlfriend will never become
a reality on top of that he and aunt may
have to shelter in happy's apartment to
hide from any spider-man conspiracy
theorists still out there reeling from
all the chaos peter thinks of the one
person who might be able to magically
make his troubles go away when peter
shows up at the sanctum sanctorum
however doctor strange informs him that
he's no longer the sorcerer supreme
because the role is so important it
needed to be filled immediately after
thanos's snap turned strange to dust in
the wind the only person who could
properly fill dr strange's shoes was of
course wang who in reality has been
working with the magical arts for longer
than strange himself while we might have
expected strange to take his position
back when he unblipped that would hardly
be fair to wang besides strange seems
perfectly content to focus on his own
pursuits and wong must be at least a
little relieved to have some say in what
hijinks strange gets up to not that
long's influence was able to prevent
strange from breaking open the
multiverse while trying to help peter
the first villain to burst onto the
scene is none other than doc ock when he
arrives he's clearly going for mass
destruction and he starts off poised to
give the mcu spider-man just as much of
a run for his money as he did in sam
raimi's spider-man 2 back in 2004
hi
do i know you
luckily today's peter has access to some
tech that doc ock's previous foe did not
when a giant metal tentacle tears into
peter's stark suit the severed nanobots
fuse into ox arms and hand over their
control to peter it's great that peter
finally has the upper hand in his fight
but how were those nanobots able to
interface with doc ox technology we have
to hand this one to tony stark who's
always able to think 1 or 10 steps ahead
of any problem he might encounter this
isn't the first time stark's tech has
been shown to be adaptable and capable
of more or less thinking for itself and
clearly peter's nanobot powered suit was
designed to change depending on the
problems he encounters no way home gives
another look at the nanobots
pseudo-intelligence later in the film
when they slither off a pacified doc ox
arms and reform into a cool looking
spider logo on peter's suit without a
doubt peter owes this lucky break to
tony and now that edith is gone this
might have been the last time his
mentor's technology is able to get him
out of gem
anyone who didn't spend the months
leading up to no way home on an internet
sabbatical knew that jamie foxx was
returning to play elektro after trailers
and still showed a very different
looking villain than the one featured in
the amazing spider-man 2 everyone began
wondering what universe this electro
really belonged to however when elektro
first arrives in the film he looks like
his old blue self for just a flash
before yellow electricity floods his
body and he changes back into a more
jaime fox looking version of the
character i'm happy we got a new new a
brand new star brand new a brand new
look
there are a few different things going
on with electro's transformation outside
the world of the movies electro's design
in the amazing spider-man 2 wasn't
particularly popular so a reskin was
never going to be out of the question no
way home could have left the change up
to the magic of the multiverse but the
film actually takes a bigger step
towards a genuine explanation since he
first gained his powers elektra's body
has been entirely composed of the
electrical energy in his world he says
that the electricity in the mcu feels
different and more powerful than that of
his home universe it doesn't take a
scientist to imagine that drawing on a
different form of energy to create his
body could give electro a different look
so
how are all these bad guys alive this
was one of the biggest questions leading
up to the release of no way home and the
film doesn't come right out with a solid
answer for it each of spidey's
multiversal villains seem to have been
pulled into the mcu from a point very
near their death in their own universes
doc ock and sandman remember the death
of norman osborne and elektro can recall
the lizard story but none of the
villains are aware of their own fate
elektro gives the clearest answer as he
states that the last thing he can
remember is spider-man using an
overloaded power grid against him in
battle from that it seems safe to assume
that all the villains were pulled from
the third acts of their respective
stories the presence of some other
important figures from previous
universes raises even more questions
both multiversal spiderman explicitly
arrived from some point in time after
they were last seen on the big screen
obviously that's great for the audience
and it gives us a deeper sense of
closure with the characters but no way
home doesn't explain why there's such a
discrepancy between the heroes and the
villains this one will have to be
chalked up to the magic of the
multiverse
one of the best parts about no way home
is getting to see peter's friends truly
join in on all the action ned and mj
play key roles in the film and without
their help there's no way that peter
would have survived to see a brand new
day ned has been peter's man in the
chair since homecoming but he takes a
big step up in this adventure when ned
and mj first arrive at the sanctum
sanctorum he mentions a rumor in his
family that some of their ancestors had
magical abilities later ned ends up with
doctor strange's sling ring and sure
enough he's able to use it to open
multiple portals throughout the film ned
is astounded by his new abilities but
his grandmother who presumably could
have some deeper insight into the
family's magical past hardly blinks an
eye we already know that magical
abilities aren't necessarily linked to
lineage unless it's later revealed that
doctor strange has some magic in his
family's past he became a sorcerer
through nothing more mysterious than
rigorous study and hard work it's
possible that some latent ability in
ned's genetics allowed him to focus some
energy through a sling ring with ease
but without further instruction it's
unlikely that he'll become a true
sorcerer of course we have to wonder
does ned even remember using magic now
when spider-man villains from alternate
universes start arriving in the mcu
peter is determined to help doctor
strange capture them and return them to
their own worlds that all changes when
peter discovers that almost all the
villains he's captured died in their
universes knowing that returning them
home means sending them to their
imminent deaths peter resolves to find a
way to save them all the simple solution
for saving the villains is to cure them
of their various abilities after all if
spider-man's foes aren't super powered
they won't need to fight the hero to the
death it takes some multiversal
assistance and some serious sacrifice
for peter to find a cure for each of the
five baddies he's up against ultimately
he's able to de-power everyone before
repairing the cracks in the universe and
sending them all home how does that
impact the original universe of each
villain no way home doesn't show what
happens in the raimiverse and web verse
when everyone returns but the changes
are undoubtedly huge no one would
remember their time in the mcu but all
the villains would be returned to good
guy status or at least neutral guy
status well before they died because
harry osborne didn't need to seek
revenge for his father's death is he
still alive in the remyverse without the
final battle against electro taking
place is gwen stacy alive in the
webverse all that could be on the table
now but we'll have to wait for future
announcements to know for sure
at the climax of no way home the
multiverse is collapsing and doctor
strange is doing everything in his power
to prevent all of reality from being
pulled into the confines of the mcu
clearly whatever is coming through from
alternate universes would be immensely
destructive but strange plays koi about
the specifics of the danger they're
coming he tells peter but he doesn't
bother to explain who they are they're
starting to come through
and i can't stop them two possibilities
seem most likely here first marvel's
what if on disney plus has already shown
that there's no shortage of dangerous
characters out in the multiverse on the
other hand eternals recently introduced
a whole slew of new dangers into the mcu
in strange's struggle against the
multiverse mysterious glowing figures
are only briefly shown peeking through
the cracks of reality but the visuals
had a striking resemblance to some of
the celestials we've already seen
considering how dangerous a single
celestial can be an army of them would
be more than enough to make strange
sweat bullets either way it seems very
likely that the multiverse of madness
will give us further
hints venom let there be carnage sent
shockwaves through the nerd world with
its end credit scene eddie brock and
venom were transported into the mcu just
in time to see peter parker's secret
identity revealed on the news by
mysterio and j jonah jameson we all
wondered if this meant venom was
officially part of the mcu and whether
or not he would team up with the other
baddies in no way home to create the
sinister six however eddie brock and his
favorite parasite made only a brief
appearance in the film's mid-credits
scene eddie is seen at a bar getting up
to speed on the incredible events of the
mcu but then he's transported away when
doctor strange closes the multiverse
though a small piece of symbiote is left
behind the scene raises more questions
than it answers
all we know for now is that a small
piece of venom has officially made its
way into the mcu
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one